die gescheiterte pkw maut und die folgen
für scheuer
ein untersuchungsausschuss soll mögliche
fehler des verkehrsministers aufdecken e
mails als klimakiller
das internet verursacht weltweit genauso
viel co2 wie der gesamte flugverkehr
glückliche leipziger nach unentschieden
der bundesligist schafft in der
champions league erstmals den einzug ins
achtelfinale
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am donnerstag mit
sport von arbeitnehmern in und verliere
minuten ein schreiben von mir
das debakel um die geplatzte pkw maut
hat ein parlamentarisches nachspiel
noch im dezember wird sich ein
untersuchungsausschuss mit möglichen
fehlern von verkehrsminister scheuer und
ihren folgen befassen
so haben die vier oppositionsparteien im
bundestag entschieden
scheuer gerät damit weiter unter druck
dem minister wird vor allem vorgeworfen
er habe die maut verträge voreilig
abgeschlossen noch bevor klar war ob sie
rechtlich zulässig sind
zudem sei den maut- betreibern ein hoher
schadensersatz zugesichert worden falls
die maut nicht so komme wie geplant
darüber hinaus zeige scheuer nur wenig
bereitschaft aufzuklären was mit den
firmen alles abgesprochen wurde
der verkehrsminister weist die vorwürfe
zurück
christiane hübscher verkehrsminister
scheuer ist gar nicht da als der
bundestag mit den stimmen von fdp linken
grünen und afd den
untersuchungsausschuss zur pkw-maut
offiziell einsetzt die koalitionspartner
enthalten sich behandelt der ausschuss
der u ausschuss soll nun prüfen was der
bundesrechnungshof dem minister bereits
schriftlich gab er habe mit der maut das
vergaberecht verletzt gegen
haushaltsrecht verstoßen und die
großzügige schadensersatz regelungen die
scheuer vorab mit dem mautbetreiber
schloss sie war nicht angemessen
er scheue wollte die maut durchsetzen
koste es was es wolle gegen den
widerstand seiner beamten hat er vor der
verkündung des urteils des europäischen
gerichtshofs fakten geschaffen und
dadurch einen riesigen schaden für den
deutschen steuerzahler von bis zu 500
millionen euro wir wollen konkret wissen
was es in den geheimgesprächen andreas
scheuer mit den konzernchefs von kaprun
eventim wirklich gelaufen das gibt es
keine akten
entscheidende informationen fehlten oder
waren geschwärzt in den akten die
scheuer mit großer geste persönlich in
den bundestag gebracht hatte bis zuletzt
aber versprach er größtmögliche
transparenz
mit einem eigenen gutachten das bei uns
im haus mit infrastrukturabgabe alles
sehr sehr seriös gelaufen ist in zwei
wochen beginnt der
untersuchungsausschuss zu arbeiten
geleitet von einem spd abgeordneten
ich werde auch darauf achten dass hier
mit fairen mitteln anständigen mitteln
in diesem ausschuss gearbeitet wird wir
sind weder ankläger noch sind wir
verteidiger sondern wir sind in diesem
ausschuss aufklärer wie viel
schadensersatz die mautbetreiber nach
der kündigung vom staat genau verlangen
wird auch der ausschuss erst anfang
kommenden jahres erfahren sollen junge
leute künftig nach der schule ein jahr
zur bundeswehr gehen oder einen
sozialdienst machen müssen
cdu-chefin kramp karrenbauer wirbt für
eine dienstpflicht für frauen und männer
schauen wir kurz zurück
2011 wurde die wehrpflicht abgeschafft
rund 70.000 wehrdienstleistende im jahr
fielen weg und damit auch 90.000
zivildienstleistende der danach
eingeführte bundesfreiwilligendienst mit
jährlich 40.000 hat das nicht
ausgeglichen
florian hahn über eine auch in der union
umstritten die idee sich um alte
menschen kümmern oder in der pflege
aushelfen
zehntausende jugendliche machen das
derzeit freiwillig sollte man künftig
ganze jahrgänge dazu verpflichten die
jugendlichen die wir heute zufällig in
bremen treffen sind nicht begeistert ist
man das jetzt ein aufzwingen dass sich
jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt keine gute
idee sich persönlich er jetzt auch keine
lust darauf denn wenn man hat schon eine
vorstellung hat von seiner zukunft
möchte man sie hat natürlich selbst
verfolgen dann ist es so dann wie bei
schule wenn dann die schüler anfangen zu
schwänzen und dann gehen die dann nicht
hin und so berlin cdu zentrale die
parteivorsitzende hat zum sogenannten
werkstattgespräch geladen will über die
dienstpflicht diskutieren die sie schon
2018 gefordert hatte
annegret kramp-karrenbauer das ziel den
zusammenhalt stärken ihre frage
es muss es eine pflicht sein oder kann
soll und muss er ein verbessertes
freiwilliges angebot sein
im laufe der diskussion wird deutlich
dass auch in den eigenen reihen viele
den freiwilligendienst bevorzugen
freiwilligkeit heißt junge menschen sind
überzeugt für unser land etwas zu tun
und das sollten wir stärken
das sehen die sozialverbände die die
jungen leute beschäftigen müssten
genauso unsere gesellschaft sollte
ringen um die gute haltung und
einstellung der menschen und pflicht es
sozusagen die letzte option widerstand
gegen die dienstpflicht also quer durch
die lager annegret kramp karrenbauer
aber will die idee nicht aufgeben und
nun erstmal ein modell entwickeln das
ist klar das ist ein langer weg und auf
diesem weg kann man auch als
zwischenschritte viele verbesserungen im
freiwilligen angebot machen für eine
dienstpflicht müsste das grundgesetz
geändert werden entsprechende mehrheiten
nicht in sicht ohnehin müsste sie erst
noch ihre eigene partei überzeugen
die us-unterstützung für die
demokratiebewegung in hongkong belastet
das verhältnis zu china aufs neue
präsident trump hat zwei gesetzte mit
sanktionen unterschrieben die der
kongress nahezu einstimmig beschlossen
hatte china reagiert wütend bestellt den
amerikanischen botschafter ein und droht
mit gegenmaßnahmen ulf röller auswickeln
es wird chinas machthaber nicht gefallen
den hong kong singen sie die
amerikanische nationalhymne
die vereinigten staaten sind die neuen
hoffnungsträger der demokratiebewegung
seit präsident trump das gesetz
unterschrieben hat dass hongkongs
demonstranten schützen soll
donald trump ist donald trump
unterstützt unseren kampf um freiheit
und die menschenrechte die uns china bei
der übergabe garantiert hat das freut
uns darum sind wir hier keine
öffentliche unterschrift feier im weißen
haus trampel china nicht provozieren
aber der innenpolitische druck zwang ihn
wohl zu handeln heute habe ich das
gesetz 1838 das hong kong menschenrechts
und demokratie gesetz von 2009/10
unterzeichnet lässt er erklären die hong
kong politik der usa könnte die
verhandlung zur beendigung des handels
krieges mit china belasten
peking droht jedenfalls
wir raten den usa nicht stur zu bleiben
andernfalls für china gegenmaßnahmen
ergreifen und alle sich daraus
ergebenden konsequenzen müssen von den
usa getragen werden die krise hongkongs
ist auf der großen bühne angekommen und
droht den riss zwischen den weltmächten
usa und china noch weiter zu vertiefen
die nato sei hirntot hatte frankreichs
präsident ma con in einem interview
erklärt jetzt legt er noch einmal nach
es sei unverantwortlich wenn sich die
militärallianz weiter nur mit ihrer
finanzierung und technischen fragen
befassen
auch russland müsse stärker eingebunden
werden sagte mack rom nach einem treffen
mit nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg das
sei sein weckruf für den jubiläumsgipfel
die nato feiert nächste woche ihr 70
jähriges bestehen
es sind wohl die größten unruhen im irak
seit dem sturz von saddam hussein 2003
und sie finden kein ende bei den
blutigen demonstrationen starben seit
anfang oktober mehr als 300 menschen
tausende erlitten verletzungen
der protest richtet sich gegen
korruption und misswirtschaft auch dem
iran gelten wut und hass der
demonstranten
das nachbarland steht im verdacht die
regierung in bagdad zu beherrschen
susanna santina berichtet das iranische
konsulat brennt lichterloh
die wut der demonstranten über den
zunehmend iranischen einfluss im irak
entlädt sich gestern abend den matches
als reaktion verhängte die regierung den
ausnahmezustand
allein seit gestern wurden mindestens 40
demonstranten durch sicherheitskräfte
getötet
und der iran das sollen diese bilder die
auf twitter verbreitet werden belegen
zerlegt heute panzer nachbarschaft zur
unterstützung der vom iran kontrolliert
milizen genauso wie die streitkräfte der
irakischen regierung mit aller härte
gegen die demonstranten in diesen tagen
vorgehen
die irakische regierung will vom
einfluss des nachbarn nichts wissen
[Musik]
unsere regierung arbeitet unabhängig vom
iran sagt der sprecher des
ministerpräsidenten
natürlich haben die menschen das recht
zu protestieren aber die demonstranten
dürfen nicht die rechte anderer iraker
einschränken dass der iran schon länger
großen einfluss auf die irakische
politik ausübt dafür gibt es viele
belege
dabei hilft dem mullah-regime dass
hochrangige iranische politiker wie
ministerpräsident macht die während der
herrschaft von saddam hussein lange exil
jahre im iran verbrachten im irak sind
es bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände seit 33
tagen ein motor der proteste wie hier in
bagdad die junge generation die bei
einem durchschnittsalter im irak von 20
jahren klar in der mehrheit ist die
meisten von ihnen haben bislang nur
perspektivlosigkeit missstände und
korruption durch die politischen eliten
erlebt und wollen endlich den wandel
die regierung verspricht viel und hält
gar nichts wir haben es satt es ist
einfach genug
wir werden diesmal erfolg haben und wir
werden die regierung aus dem amt
die hat heute beschlossen einen
krisenstab des militärs einzurichten
ein rücktritt denkt ministerpräsident
macht ihr derzeit nicht nachdem juwelen
diebstahl aus dem grünen gewölbe in
dresden hat die polizei eine belohnung
ausgesetzt
eine halbe million euro für hinweise auf
die täter
bei dem raub am montag hatten unbekannte
rund 20 schmuckstücke mit hunderten
diamanten aus der zeit augusts des
starken erbeutet die polizei geht von
vier tätern aus wenige tage vor der
weltklimakonferenz hat das
europaparlament den klima notstand
ausgerufen
fast zwei drittel der abgeordneten
stimmten für die symbolträchtige
resolution
die staaten sind damit aufgefordert
sofortige maßnahmen zu ergreifen um die
auswirkungen des klimawandels zu
begrenzen
konkret soll zum beispiel die co2
emissionen bis 2030 stärker gesenkt
werden
verpflichtend sind die maßnahmen
allerdings nicht und wir bleiben noch
beim thema klima
elisabeth schmidt berichtet über ein
aspekt über den sich bisher wohl kaum
jemand gedanken gemacht hat
auch e-mails verursachen treibhausgase
der grund ist der enorm hohe
energieverbrauch der rechenzentren die
rund um die uhr laufen die weltweite
nutzung des internets verursache genauso
viel co2 wie der flugverkehr schreiben
wissenschaftler in einer studie
auch so kann umweltverschmutzung
aussehen energieforscher haben berechnet
eine stunde video streaming produziert
genauso viel co2 wie ein kilometer
autofahren einmal googeln 0,2 gramm co2
eine e mail ein gramm und verschicken in
deutschland täglich eine milliarde
e-mails und das bedeutet dass pro tag
alleine ungefähr 1000 tonnen co2 jahre
zahlen bei jeder internet aktivität
arbeiten server
diese benötigen energie und verursachen
dadurch co2 allein in den vergangenen
neun jahren ist der energieverbrauch von
rechenzentren in deutschland um 40
prozent gestiegen
dabei kann jeder internetnutzer energie
und damit treibhausgasemissionen
es bringt zum beispiel was e mails zu
löschen die sie nicht mehr brauchen was
man noch braucht auch gerne archivieren
auf zum beispiel einer festplatte oder
optischen datenträger wie cd dvd die
keine energie braucht werden etwa fotos
gelöscht wird speicherplatz in einer
cloud frei server benötigen dann weniger
energie doch auch rechenzentren können
energiesparen beispiel tüv nord in
hannover
statt mit klimaanlagen wird hier
weitgehend mit freiluft gekühlt der tüv
spart dadurch 750 tonnen co2 pro jahr
energie reduzieren könnten aber auch
andere rechenzentren in deutschland
maximal möglich aus unserer sicht sind
ungefähr 25 prozent einsparung in den
nächsten zehn jahren milliarden nutzen
das internet die masse macht's alle
können dazu beitragen dass weniger co2
anfällt zum mordfall walter lübke
da hat jetzt der anwalt des
hauptverdächtigen stephanie ein neues
geständnis seines mandanten angekündigt
bereits nach seiner festnahme hatte der
die tat gestanden das geständnis dann
aber zurückgezogen
das hessische landeskriminalamt gab
heute bekannt dass bei stephanie
außerdem eine ältere datensammlung mit
60 personen und objekten gefunden wurde
er habe informationen über personen des
öffentlichen lebens und über gebäude wie
rathäuser im großraum kassel gesammelt
pflegeangebote wie betreutes wohnen oder
senioren wgs werden immer beliebter
180 tausend menschen in deutschland
leben inzwischen in solchen
einrichtungen
sie sind für die krankenkassen aber oft
teurer als pflegeheime
das ist das ergebnis einer studie der
barmer krankenkasse henriette de
maizière fasst zusammen wohngemeinschaft
stadt altenheim zusammen mit vier
anderen leben antonio den outer und
brigitte gremelmayr in einer senioren wg
in stuttgart eigene wohnung plus
gemeinschaftsräume für die bewohner ein
glück man wird hier auch unterstützt
sage ich auch mal von informationen der
eine weiß dieses wie gehe ich mit dem
tablet um der andere weiß wieder wie
kann ich mir aus der bibliothek etwas
besorgen was mir zum vorteil gereicht
also man ist ja permanent damit auch
auch geistig luft beschäftigt der
idealzustand doch der heute in berlin
vorgestellten barmer pflegereport zeigt
eine wohngemeinschaft oder betreutes
wohnen bietet in einzelnen fällen mehr
lebensqualität nicht jedoch bessere
pflegequalität im pflegeheim ist dafür
sorge tragen dass 24 stunden jemand da
ist der aufpasst dass die versorgung
stimmt ihm betreuten wohnen kaufen sie
einzelne leistungen dazu das heißt haben
diese garantie die vollversorgung nicht
das führt zum beispiel deutlich häufiger
zu fällen von wundliegen laut barmer
pflegereport pflege wgs und heimen
rechtlich nicht gleichgestellt auch wenn
die bewohner pflegebedürftig sind und
pflegegeld beziehen
doch es fehlen kontrollen die forderung
einheitliche qualitätsstandards
unabhängig davon davon in welcher form
pflege erbracht wird ob im heim in einem
betreuten einrichtung für betreutes
wohnen oder in einer pflege wg
einheitliche standards und transparenz
damit der wunsch nach eigenständigen
aber auch gut betreut im leben im alter
gegeben ist
ja und nun zu dir norbert und sue
fußball-champions-league es erstmal zum
bvb dortmund muss um den einzug ins
achtelfinale bangen
und nur vier fahrer um seinen trainerjob
ein starker auftritt von weltstar lionel
messi bei der enttäuschenden 1 3
auswärts niederlage der borussia gegen
den fc barcelona
dortmund kommt in barcelona nicht voran
in sachen krisenbewältigung das urteil
der vereinsführung eindeutig wenn man 3
1 verliert dann ist es sicherlich kein
schritt aus der krise
der bvb auch mit guten phasen treffen
sich aber zu anfällig der überragende
messi auch solaris 10 29 vier minuten
später assistiert schwarz-gelb
fehlpasses messi vollendet dortmund
verpasst den schritt in die richtige
richtung
er wäre es gewesen wenn wir heute hier
in punkt geholt hätten oder vielleicht
sogar gewonnen hätten bass chris mann
erhöht in der 67 minute auf drei zu null
jaden sancho kann für den bvb in der 77
nur noch verkürzen
sancho aus disziplinarischen gründen
erst in der zweiten halbzeit dabei
dortmund muss samstag zur hertha nach
berlin es ist ein job endspiel für
trainer favre leipzig dagegen hat
geliefert vor allem weil er geliefert
hat e mail forsberg der doppeltorschütze
beim mühevollen 2 zu 2 im heimspiel
gegen benfica lissabon
er verhalf rb zum erstmaligen einzug ins
achtelfinale der champions league
der mann des spiels emil forsberg in der
neunzigsten minute leipzig liegt 0 2
hinten foulelfmeter 1 2
hoffnung keimt auf die der schwede in
der fünften von insgesamt neun minuten
nachspielzeit in glückseligkeit
verwandelt sein erstes kopfballtor in
fast 160 spielen für leipzig vorher
leipzig oft unsicher 20 minuten führung
lissabon durch pc
nach knapp einer stunde erhöhte
portugals meister sogar auf zwei zu null
durch mini cius nach forsberg doppelpack
steht leipzig dann doch im champions
league achtelfinale erstmals in zehn
jahren klubgeschichte dass wir das jetzt
frühzeitig geschafft haben vor dem
letzten spiel ist etwas großartiges
ein historischer erfolg für leipzig dank
e mail vossberg also e on bayern schule
machte finale dortmund leverkusen können
wir auch noch schaffen in zwei wochen
für die bleibt spannend
zum wetter das wird im norden freundlich
aber gelegentlich auch nass im süden ist
dagegen mit dauerregen zu rechnen
gunther tiersch gleich mit den
einzelheiten
so viel von uns für den moment marietta
slomka erwartet sie um drei viertel 10
zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen abend wieder da
danke dass sie dabei waren noch einen
gemütlichen abend für sie und
[Musik]
und da bliebe zuschauer kältere tage
sind jetzt in sicht entscheidend dafür
ist unser regengebiet das heute über
deutschland lag das tief zieht nach
nordosten ab und jetzt kann eben die
luft direkt von der nordsee kommen sie
ist kühler und sie ist vor allen dingen
auch trockener deshalb gibt es morgen
norddeutschland ein bisschen
sonnenschein im süden allerdings dichte
wolken und dauerregen heute nacht haben
den dauerregen eigentlich fast überall
erst so später wird es von nordwesten
ein bisschen auflockern dazu in der
zweiten nachthälfte sturmböen aus
nordwesten an der nordsee auch sonst ist
die nacht sehr windig vielleicht gibt es
morgen früh zumindest in
schleswig-holstein leichten bodenfrost
tagsüber haben wir dann im norden einen
wechsel von sonne wolken regenschauer
die regenschauer ziehen von der nordsee
richtung harz aber auch im osten an der
ostsee in brandenburg kam ein paar
schauer abends vielleicht sogar schon
mit schneeregen und es ist weiterhin
sehr windig vor allen dingen an der
ostsee in der mitte ist es freundlich
bis zum einen da scheint zeitweise die
sonne aber dann wird es dich dass regnet
anhalten an den alpen sinkt bis zum
abend die schneefallgrenze etwa auf 1000
meter und dann kann es auch am main
schon hier und da ein bisschen
auflockern
die temperaturen nicht mehr ganz so hoch
es sind noch etwa fünf bis zehn grad
aber es wird eben noch kühler in den
nächsten tagen samstag ganz freundlich
dann der sonntag von südwesten mit
schneeregen oder schnee und auch der
montag eine ziemlich kite ich wünschen
noch einen schönen abend und machen sie
es gut